&gt;&gt; Let's take a moment to examine these values of x, the amount we're increasing
each dimension by, and A, the total area of Grant's display space, or at least
the ones that we've seen so far. The original area, before we added anything to
either dimension, was 150 square feet. When we added 1 foot in each direction,
the area changed 176 square feet. So in the transition from this point to this
point, x went up by 1 and A went up by 26. Let's see what happens in the next
transition. Once again, x went up by 1. But this time, A increased by 28 instead
of 26. This is what we call nonlinear behavior. Remember that for a straight
line, which we can write as y equals mx plus b, m, the slope, is going to be the
same, regardless of which points we pick. The change in x is always going to be
the same. The change in x value is always going to have the same proportion to
change in y value. The change between two x values and the change between two y
values is always going to obey the same ratio. That is not what's happening
here. This equation no longer applies. A change of 1 foot in dimension doesn't
always increase the area by the same amount. This is a pretty interesting
problem to have. Remembering that area is equal to length times width, can you
come up with an equation that we can use to figure out what value of x will give
us an area of 300 square feet? So think about how x will be involved in both the
length and the width of this new area.